the game and the computer maybe he's had
a word with a coach and he'll be his
mind will be ticking and there we see a
prag opens with the King spawn
so it's the Italian opening one of the
most popular openings of 2022 and both
Bishops are out now this tends to lead
to a tense
peace packed position with very few
exchanges in the early early phase and
okay this Pawn push is just for black
star to go Bishop to retreat there are
so many different move orders in this
opening Ivanka is confusing for even top
players I feel and I Know It confuses me
at least all the different nuances here
I'm relieved to hear that David because
I tried to take up this opening and
there were so many move orders like like
the night moves the pawn moves forward
and so many pieces on the board that I
thought okay I cannot handle this
attention leave it to the experts like
exactly but it seemed to me that white
wasn't playing the most aggressive moves
but then suddenly like 20 moves down the
line
what has a fantastic position and you're
like how
exactly I mean I've been playing this
opening my whole career as white and I
still didn't understand all the ideas
and uh these top players they've worked
out all these different plans these
different move orders I think the reason
this is so popular for white despite the
computer not always being impressed it's
just because it keeps the tension and it
is black who often gets impatient and
lashes out in the center and uh kind of
lives to regret that so uh White tonight
now just stepping out onto a slightly
awkward square but it will re-route
itself towards the king side later and
uh the reason in these types of
positions we do say that white has a
small Advantage it's a very tiny Factor
let's just jump in to show this it's a
long-term Factor however it's because
this Knight which looks very nicely
centralized is actually dominated by
this Pawn anywhere the white Knights the
Black Knight wants to jump is controlled
by this piece and uh due to that white
is the one ready to push forward in the
center white is controlling this key
square and black often struggles to
prevent this Pawn push and he's just
moving his Rook I'm expecting uh Prague
either to push this Pawn just to take
away the G4 Square from Black's Knight
Black's bishop or to play copycat and to
move his Rook across and this is very
thematic because White Knight wants to
retreat and hop next to its fellow here
with knights on these two squares uh
White often has great attacking
potential but first he prepares this
pragnananda and it's just very difficult
for a niche as black to find a plan in
the current position black maybe wants
to trade off these Bishops do you go for
it now can you trade off these Bishops
on your terms uh black often exactly
plays this move black often Retreats his
Bishop black Waits until the tension is
resolved but it's hard psychologically
in these types of positions every piece
remaining on the board yeah definitely
and all the pawn breaks still on the
board and there we see we finally have
some clear intentions uh and each wants
to trade off the light Square bishop and
this is what I was talking about white
often says no I don't want to do that
and uh Retreats it to what is a
seemingly terrible square
but you mark my words 20 moves down that
line that light Square Bishop that was
sudden the terrible square is going to
be a monster ah now it's going to open
up potentially on this diagonal so first
you need to achieve this Pawn push you
need five ten moves to prepare that and
later on maybe if there's an exchange of
points in the center you push this
button forward and suddenly great
diagonal for the bishop to sit on so
you'll write your bank it's all about
potential and talking of potential black
drops is Bishop back because it's on a
potential great diagonal itself and the
position is heating up very quickly
let's jump to the current position black
was the first to push a ball in the
center just on the Lasko pushing this
pawn and white has traded off meaning
that there's an attack against the
Central Pawn and each defends against
that by recapturing making sure his Rook
defends to spawn and now although black
has the better Pawn structure Black's
Pawn in the middle very strong holding
some key squares but it is also a
weakness and it ties down much of
Black's army look at Anish giri on the
camera right now he has studied this
position before but he's trying to
remember what to do and it's not easy as
black I think I've seen this position
before myself as well but I wouldn't be
able to tell you what I I want to do
here as black often you want to move the
queen you want to bring it the center
but again what next you're a bit stuck
and white meanwhile is ready with this
Knights to jump forward and start an
attack yeah I mean this position
definitely feels familiar but checking
the database I can see only three games
in this exact position that's the thing
it looks familiar to me as well but I
can't remember what I studied I can't
remember if it's this position maybe in
that position Black's the one that I've
studied maybe black Bishop was on a
different Square maybe that's a big
difference
it's uh so hard even for the top Grand
Masters like anishagiri opening experts
like him yeah to figure out all the
different concepts and he does indeed
move his Queen getting ready to improve
his worst piece that is The Rook once
Black's Rook centralizes most problems
are solved and it's not too scary right
now for the White Knight to step forward
because the black queen might Retreat
losing a move yes but the Knight now
would simply be attacked losing some
time for white as well
um yeah Prague with 16 minutes what will
he do to try and put Gary under some
pressure white pieces don't look too
impressive right now they don't look too
active so at some point you will want to
break out it's all about getting these
Bishops
still takes a while but you need to find
a way and uh one way or another there's
now still only three games on the
database but this time they've kind of
transposed to a game that was played
between Wesley so and Alexander grishek
in a rapid tournament there and Wesley
approached this position by a trading of
the dark Square Bishops and he wanted to
put pressure on Black's potentially weak
E5 Pawn yep so trading off these pieces
makes sense Black's Bishop was uh from
long range putting some serious pressure
on the white king side so if you trade
these off then uh yeah as you mentioned
nirvanka White's Queen is going to step
to the square for example like this the
white Rook is going to slide behind and
the three heavy pieces are going to gang
up against Black's Central Pawn
so some serious pressure and uh I think
that might have been on the tour from
last season uh that game it looks
familiar I've seen that game before
between Wesley so and Anish giri I'm not
sure whether it was that tournament or
another but either way some pedigree and
if it's been played by opening experts
like Russia can Wesley so then it means
that the players are following uh
following something yeah worth probably
Yes actually but who knows if it will be
one of the very best games from the 2022
season there is a vote going on you guys
uh our experts across all the chess 24
streams have nominated their favorite
games from the 2022 season and now it's
up to all of you to vote for your
favorite there will be one game
receiving an award for being the best
game of the 2022 season what games did
you guys
nominate oh one of them was by pregnant
and I nominated a game between pregnant
and Jordan van Forest where Prague uh I
think we saw a clip earlier I described
it as one of the best games I've ever
seen Prague shocked me with some some
Rook sacrifices it looked like he was
going for the king then suddenly
switched his blade to the other side of
the board there were Forks there were
pins there were double attacks skewers
everything
um but uh also Again by mamadura
and since David took the two of my two
favorites I I actually picked one
between eragisi and Liam lay because it
was massively complicated such a crazy
game and uh Eric icy was just playing
for normal chasing sacrificing some
pawns with check and it's well worth a
place wow and yeah on chess24.com tour
you can cast your wrote and also look
through these games we've made videos
with Recaps of these fantastic games
from the season so take a look at that
and cast your vote now this one the bar
is roughly in the middle does it have
potential to be one of those uh games
that you just remember
could well be especially when someone
like Prague is in charge of the white
pieces look at what he's doing those
white Knights they've gone to slightly
weird squares but they're about to hop
back towards the center to try and
create some attacks probably looks so
focused it's like he's trying to jump
into his computer screen here
um he's determined not just to sit on
his one point advantage in the match
today he wants to go For Broke he wants
to go all in and double up his Advantage
yeah why not yeah what do you think of
this uh there's two white Knights on the
edge of the board now they're on the
edge of the board but they have a
purpose and they're definitely going to
one of them is going to sit on the F5
square and put pressure on the black
position I also quite like the idea of
trading off the dark Square bishop and
go for it and goes for it just as I say
I really do feel like I've won a little
Bingo or jackpot when the players play
the move that I suggest so I like this
uh option yeah and very logical as well
yeah swapping off an undeveloped piece
previously for Black's long-range Bishop
and uh whilst Anish is thinking about a
plan well we do have a caption this
competition yes
and we've asked you guys at home to
caption this very cool picture of David
and Simon and Arbor Gideon says
oh the Bishops have traded off are we
going to get the picture the able
Guardian Gideon there you go he says
every group project there's David has no
idea what's going on the whole time it
does 95 of the work yeah
always have one person in the group yes
yes
that's me
and there we see the pawn a step forward
to guard the F5 square and whilst
there's another pause in the game we
also see another entry from Kelvin who
shares with us a picture of Simon and
David and says
wait for it it's quite good I love it's
worth the wait there you go how to wait
for Harry the H Pawn to be pushed
it's always worth the wait as always
and I love how Simon Just he looks so
they're calm like okay yeah yeah or even
a little annoyed this is my camera David
no I mean he's he's saying oh Harry gets
pushed every game anyway and I'm like
whoa whatever
yeah it's uh oh I miss Simon I'm excited
yeah
it's uh okay meanwhile it's a pretty
much going according to the plan we
outlined earlier just white tripling up
on the e-file blacks Pawn in the middle
of the board now for Anish is under
threat it is attacked twice it's only
defended once
I just love this it's almost an
alakyne's gun when uh tripled pieces the
Rooks and queens the heavy pieces they
were all lined up on the same file
normally it's two Rooks at the front and
then the queen kind of pushes from
behind uh supports from behind but here
White's Queen is going to be sandwiched
between its two rocks when White's rook
in the corner slides behind her but uh
yeah it's gonna be really hard for
anishikiru to deal with that pressure
I'm a bit surprised with how he's set up
actually Black's night now in the middle
of the board blocking the black Rook on
the e-file doesn't make a great
impression it certainly doesn't make a
great impression I mean if he wants to
hold on to that pawn he's gonna have to
move that Knight one more time again
perhaps to where it came from although
although maybe that one doesn't even
work I actually just realized yeah it
doesn't look great uh for Anish I've got
to say the evaluation bar still not
impressed still smack bang in the middle
but
it's white about to win a pawn maybe any
scary does he have to sacrifice his Pawn
in the middle and Go Active again that's
not necessarily his style
um he's reluctant to sacrifice in
general and there we go the Knight moves
back
but it just came from there three moves
ago Black's Knight moved away from the
square went back and anisha's lost
valuable time and that's why the
evaluation bar goes in White's favorite
I think he had to be active there uh
Ivanka I think okay nice shoes but he's
shaking his foot that's a sign of nerves
from energy
and uh it's a sign of nerves because
he's just lost to Tempe as we say and uh
there we go very logical Prague doesn't
even need to think doesn't need to
calculate just play on Instinct improve
your worst place piece
it's a good chess strategy when there's
nothing to be done no fireworks to try
and uh try and understand just improve
your pieces yeah
and it does feel like things are going
to be heating up within the next few
moves especially along the A-line as you
mentioned I mean that's all about
opening that line in the best way
possible
yeah so the question is can you open it
now do you have to wait a moment a
moment or two how does white improve now
because the white Knights look pretty
decent White's Bishop struggles to
improve itself or it's heavy pieces the
Rooks and queen
they look great so what next for preg
has he maximized the potential of his
position already or are there other ways
forward I know what Magnus Carlson would
do here uh he would stop pushing some
pawns he loves pushing pawns gaining
space
so if magnets were in Prague shoes I'm
pretty sure we would see one of these
two pawns push forward uh Magnus he's
this is his trademark essentially uh to
gain space on all sides of the board I
was going to say maybe this Pawn first
but you have to be slightly careful that
black could grab this loan this kind of
uh this Lone Ranger on A2 maybe you
could push the other Pawn forward first
the whole idea here for example of black
weights I'm not sure how the whole idea
is to push the pawns forward together in
tandem uh just to undermine this Black
Knight if you can undermine this Knight
then suddenly the pawn in the center on
E5 will drop off the board
so to me this looks logical
what else could we stumble across here
you mentioned Ivanka trying to open up
the center I mean one thing you could
calculate is whether you could play this
Pawn push I don't think you can right
now but uh I was just trying to look for
some tactics for example the reason
Craig could calculate this is because
you could dream potentially of
sacrificing
the reason this doesn't work is because
black skin has a choice of two squares
you've given up here a queen for rook
and Knight but if you choose the wrong
square with black then suddenly White
Knight jumps into the game with a double
attack with a fork it might be captured
but the other Knight replaces it and uh
White would win material the downside
here unfortunately is that Black's King
does have two squares and it can run to
the side of the board no checks and it's
safe but already it's nearly working
yeah it is almost working and and in the
final sorry in the starting in the
original position I mean the other move
to kind of calculate is whether a knight
can just plonk itself on the F5 square
and uh sacrifice color
this is similar to what Gary did against
Prague in the last game sacrifice
tonight and then try and figure out what
to do later yeah and the problem is that
you should you shouldn't just sacrifice
the night just like that and for trying
to figure out you mean you have you have
to have the backup there yeah and it
doesn't work unfortunately that's
because the black queen can jump back
and defend her pawn and Black's King
will just hide out in the corner uh it
will hide it in on h8 and it should be
safe so practice Retreats the game will
take a Karma a Karma
it's just got a common nature right now
uh due to this retreat no attack yet but
he is attacking a Pawn Yeah and we'll
take the route to San Francisco we know
there are four great chess players
international Master our roving report
to Tanya is there and are there any VIP
guests in the building today Tanya
yes Kyle I'm here with a very special
guest he's adjustable author a very
popular streamer International Master
Costa kavitsky is joining us hey Caster
hey how's it going thanks it's going
well but you tell us are you excited to
have the finals in your city yeah super
excited I know you guys are worldwide
and um I've been in San Francisco for
for many years I played a lot of events
here and uh
yeah I mean it's so great to see such a
big event uh here
and you're you're a streamer yourself
what does it mean to you to see chess
evolve into this esport
uh it's amazing yeah I think people
don't realize chess uh in the Chess
World has really changed in the last
five years like dramatically just it's a
completely different game now everything
is Shifting online I still love all the
OTB events hopefully those don't go
anywhere but uh all the online action
the interest is really really I think
it's great for the game I bought from
you who's your favorite chess streamer
oh my favorite streamer oh [ __ ] that uh
it will be on the spot
um I have a lot of a lot of friends in
the world I'm a big fan of Eric Rosen
John Bartholomew uh of course I like all
the big streamers maybe maybe those are
my top two we see a very different side
of Magnus when he's streaming what do
you think about that
oh it's great yeah he has fun you know
he lets loose uh I think it we've never
had a world champion I was like so you
know kind of open with the public so I
think that's amazing I think the fans
absolutely love that I wish Magnus would
would stream more
like she's that is that happening do you
know
well he's not playing the World
Championship anymore so maybe we might
see him uh stream more because I have to
ask you you've got these two big courses
adjustable one of them is on end games
and Magnus in fact is one of the players
arguably one of the best NBA players
would you agree with that oh yeah
definitely one of the best endgame
players of all time uh I'd be happy to
talk about the course a little bit
that's okay it's on um it's on end game
studies which I'm sure you you've solved
and many players have saw that are very
very difficult and tricky and
essentially I just wanted to make an
introductory course for friend game
studies so players can learn like how to
solve some of these like trickier like
end game tactics and game puzzles and
learn how to like calculate a little bit
deeper in in the end game and I I feel
endgame is one of those uh parts of the
game that we often tend to not look into
that much but it's such a crucial part
and you can win so many points if you're
good at it yeah absolutely in some some
parts of the world they teach the end
game first right that's like how you
actually learn to play the game you got
to learn teaser King and use your pawns
and then slowly you like figure out the
rest of the game but yeah chess is so
complicated and I think no no amount of
uh the benefit to studying the in-game I
think no limit your other big course is
about converting winning advantages one
of the toughest things to do in chess is
to win a winning game tell us about that
yeah I think it's one of the the biggest
issues in chess I certainly struggle
with it people can look at my games to
see tons of uh missed wins and missed
opportunities so yeah the idea with that
course there was to give folks kind of
uh some strategies try to convert the
position you know things like the
principle of two weaknesses and how to
make the right exchanges how to convert
to an end game that like you know you
can win and how to like close out points
right without giving away the the draw
such a big part of the game and who do
you think does it best who's got that
killer instinct oh well uh Magnus for
sure I think some of the best technique
of all time you know Smith love uh
famously said I'm gonna make 40 good
moves and my opponent also makes 40 good
moves we'll make a draw I think Magnus
has doubled that number to 80. I think
it's 80 moves now you gotta apply
against him to hold awesome and finally
who are we rooting for here at the
metwater Champions Chester final
probably not 100 he's he's just like
that other dog he's a kid he's so good
um I mean I like all the players here
you know Magnus Geary uh Wesley but uh
product is amazing so it'd be cool to
see him win I love it I'm gonna
high-five you on that one all right
thanks Costa
we have some Prague fans in the building
and some great chess players as well I
love that some accessible courses that
we all definitely should check out and
game studies one-on-one that sounds cool
actually to study the m game with Costa
all right nowhere nowhere near the end
game in this game yet I guess but is it
heating up it is heating up and Anish
giri is just set a really sneaky trap
for pregnant under to fall into I think
I would have been very tempted to fall
into this especially in a Blitz game but
if you get greedy now with white and
capture a pawn you lose on the spot and
uh it looks like you're ganged up on
this Pawn you're attacking it once twice
uh also with the rook and queen so
you're attacking this Pawn four times
it's only defended three times so you
could take it but after a capture you
have to do some counting here this is
one capture two captures three captures
four five but just at the end black
doesn't take back because this would
lead to an end game cost you show you
that this is winning for white you're a
pawn up but I unfortunately for white
here this capture is not forced first
black conflict in a really sneaky skewer
hitting the queen and the Rook behind
and the whole idea is that after Queen
takes Queen black doesn't recapture yet
you flick in a check and only after this
check winning a rook after the king
moves then do you take the White Queen
you've won a rook in the process so this
is seven I think six seven moves deep
it's quite easy to calculate because
it's just every move being a capture
every move being forced but uh that's
why maybe preg has his head in his hands
he realized that his whole idea to win
this Pawn doesn't work so that's really
sneaky from Gary it's as if he knows
what Prague wants to do and he's trying
to tempt him into it so how far down on
ratings would you have to go for someone
in a competition a tournament to fall
into that trap I think even some quite
strong players even around the 2000
Level Club oh wow players could fall
into this I think in a long game you
would sit there and calculate so it
would be quite rare but we've even seen
Grand Masters blunder In classical games
uh maybe similar ideas to this I've I
remember when I was young even after
reaching 2000 I would blunder into these
types of things occasionally but uh okay
look at what Prague has done remember
that variation where right at the end
black had Rook takes rook and it was
hitting the king with check so that was
in a six seven move calculation at the
end there was a nasty check so Prague
has seen that variation and he's like
okay I want to play that but first i'm
gonna get my king out of check so that's
what we call prophylaxis in chess like
seeing the future
um seeing exactly what is about to
happen and if it doesn't work in your
favor you prepare for that so you can't
play the critical variation right now
you couldn't take this Pawn but now it
is a threat for example now if black
wastes a move now you can capture
because again after all these trades uh
remember this variation we saw earlier
this doesn't work for black because
after Queen takes Queen Rook takes Rook
is not a check so you can take a rook
but white has time to save his Queen
so this is really deep stuff really
sophisticated really classy play from
both sides but with this weird looking
king move on its own it makes a weird
impression but uh it does create a
direct threat as Knight takes porn I
think uh Gary now has to deal with this
threat either by eliminating the Knight
stopping that capture or by dropping
back and defending the Pawn One More
Time
wow yeah
to be to be fair to you I'm sorry not to
be fair to you to be I was just thinking
that the bishop can take the Knight I
think it's more or less forced because
if the Knight were to retreat then there
are consequences to that the Knight was
protecting the rook and now my idea of
perhaps uh pushing in the center it
becomes very viable yeah as you say this
is a pin and Black's Rook could not be
defended sufficiently if black takes
with the e-born
so it looks like process of elimination
you're right Ivanka just why not
eliminate this Knight ideally you don't
want to give up a bishop for a night in
a semi-open position but sometimes needs
a must has to be done yeah and if that
Bishop does leave the board guess who's
going to become an amazing piece
that damn thing
sitting there on C2 that was such a bad
piece suddenly it moves as Dave is
highlighting yeah it's it's gonna wave
cup and really maybe decide the game
suddenly I would feel a bit
uncomfortable as black I've got to be
honest because this black king doesn't
have too many Defenders around it
there's still potential of some
sacrifices some night jumps to open up
the king later on
um so Gary is not out of danger despite
what the evaluation Bar says
um yeah it's it's just really tense it's
as if both sides are kind of testing
each other just with these small little
ideas saying okay I dare you to take my
knight I dare you to commit I dare you
to set this trap for me it's uh it's
just that type of dress it's really
cagey it is very cagey intense and uh
it's very difficult to handle
psychologically you feel a lot of
pressure considering every single
possibility so this is why we see a
niche thinking very very hard and whilst
Anish is considering his moves well
maybe we could be like a dear Deidre for
one of our viewers
dear Deidre is like an Agony aunt and uh
Rockstar asks us what if your partner
doesn't understand your love for chess
as I find my real life Queen is command
is as commanding as the chess Queen how
to handle
I don't say this without getting into
trouble
just gotta Embrace their their lack of
passion for chess
because sometimes you can't share
everything and yeah it's not easy to
instill that love and Trust in everyone
so yeah I try to let it slide
I'm sure they I'm sure your partner has
something that you don't understand as
well so yeah how about you Kaya um
Ivanka
leave it up for you guys
wow well I kind of think that you can
introduce chess but as a social thing
but you you married a chess player I
know I know so I don't really have that
kind of problem yeah but I do feel that
it is possible to get people interested
into the game you know not not if you're
sat there teaching them more or less if
you're just letting them play and you
just kind of get all friends together
you know bash it out and then you'll
find out that everyone if they're
allowed to talk if they're allowed to
just have fun then it will be just
incredibly enjoyable because after all
most people enjoy board games and I
don't see why chess can't be like
treated like that in a social aspect
with fun conversation laughter yeah and
I mean like in many other sports there
are a bunch of Chess couples and
ichigiri is an example I am married to
another great chess player but traveling
around with chess I have asked uh chess
players from time to time you know if
they would prefer a girlfriend or
boyfriend which is a chess player or not
then some some of them will answer
definitely not a chess player I need
someone I can talk to about other things
than chess yeah yeah it's it's a mixed
blessing if both partners are chess
players because how do you escape from
the game sometimes you need to switch
off I've known chess couples where
they're both so competitive if one of
them loses their game they won't talk to
the other they'll sometimes kick the
other one out of the room and be like no
I need to be alone I need to analyze
this game I need to I need my peace and
quiet to study but um yeah if it's a
non-chess player at least they you can
somehow get your mind off the game it's
easier to relax talk about other things
talk about other interests but yeah I
guess there's there's something to be
said for having a similar lifestyle and
yeah the shared passion yeah but I mean
I also discussing with one of my friends
she said the best relationships you'd
ever had was with a non-chess player and
you know that he would turn up at the
tournaments and he would go
wow same thing yeah and he would say you
can still win the tournament even though
she is she's had no chance whatsoever so
no you can still do it go for it and she
said it was the best time of her life
yep so embrace it that's basically our
answer to our uh the Twitter question
just embrace it and enjoy the positives
of being together with a non-chess
player we have a bunch of moves on the
board yeah I was gonna say unless they
say it's just a game and then
it's more than just a game it's uh yeah
a bunch of moves on the board and again
similar uh it's going down a similar
vein to what we discussed earlier black
had to get rid of that white knight he
had to part with his Bishop
unfortunately that was the only way to
deal with the pressure on black Central
Pawn there on E5 and that has happened
and meanwhile a couple of maneuvering
ideas
slightly surprised that Anish has
planted the black queen on the e-file
where it is stared down by one of the
white Rooks but I think we'll see
anisha's idea in action maybe now or on
the next turn Black's queen wants to
relocate itself nearer the white king
just to cover some squares maybe to
protect the black king as well meanwhile
the bishop has woken up Ivanka how funny
would it be if if you called it just 20
moves ago that white Bishop which
stepped to an ugly passive Square might
decide the game long term thank you
and she always does Bobby Fisher's
favorite piece that light squared Bishop
for white yeah I remember you telling me
this actually I think you helped me out
of the and you said well you know it's
actually the light Square Bishop despite
appearances is often better than its
counterpart yeah I don't know why it's
always the light Square Bishop maybe
it's because in the Spanish opening
Italian opening it's always that Bishop
which is preserved which is kept for
later in the game but it's always the
let's go Bishop that does the damage for
some reason um very rarely the dark
Square Bishop against the Knight you
very rarely like that combo for white
it's hard to say why but statistically
it has proven to be a better piece
and uh yeah I'm just reading some of the
tweets there some of the captions keep
them coming keep the answers coming keep
the agony on questions coming yeah we
can solve all your life problems
and uh going for trade of Queens the
king's partner is about to leave the
board maybe the coins are going to get
traded off and we'll head towards a
quieter end game no but oh it was Prague
apparently yeah that might be because
after white takes the black queen
Black's Pawn structure will be
compromised black will have double
thorns so a bit of a passive decision
from Anish Gary not the most active
Choice isn't there a critical moment
already because I'm just thinking if
everything gets traded off
then there are some pieces that are
standing on Awkward squares yeah and uh
I was actually going to say maybe
there's a trick in the position I don't
think it quite works but it's very
similar to what Wesley so did against
Magnus yesterday yes you can take the
queen it's probably the best move but
you could also maybe be a bit sneaky
throw in a check I don't think this will
work because black won't take this piece
Black's King can just move for example
we can step back and the Knight is
attacked but the whole idea is that if
Pawn takes Knight maybe against a weaker
player this would work suddenly the
white Rook would slide across with a
nasty pin but your variations on the
board of anchor this one would be
winning for white but black doesn't need
to take the bait instead keep things
simple Queen takes Queen and this is the
move you were expecting yeah I thought
there was going to be another trade
actually
okay another exchange first
it takes Knight yeah and then after then
move the Knight
to sew the whole idea to attack the pawn
and also you threaten to put the knights
and the F6 Square forking the two Rooks
yeah this is uh very attempting as well
maybe also equally strong but uh he's
attached to his light squared Bishop as
we've learned uh pregnant instead of
trading off which might have just won a
pawn he brings his Knight to the center
similar idea but this was met with Anish
giri keeping his Knight alive
attacking this Pawn
encounter and okay the question for
white is can you continue your plan if
you take the time out to defend this
Pawn you could do this for example by
moving the Knight this looks pretty
decent as well you defend this Pawn you
attack this guy on the edge of the board
but the most direct move the first move
you should calculate in any position is
always the most critical it's always a
check or capture or uh
that would move this win support and you
attack this guy black would be forced
okay this has happened black would be
forced to move this Pawn I think this is
what we'll see Anish do push the spawn
forward and the question is do you have
to retreat this Knight if you Retreat
black does have the time the luxury now
of taking this Pawn back maybe with his
own Rook or with his Knight
and uh this is getting complicated
struggling to see how Prague in this
position this is the current position
how he keeps both his Knight to life and
this porn of life
can you see it Ivanka
um I I'm thinking
that maybe you can attack the Knight but
uh yeah it's just because Prague is the
master of counter-attacks I mean there
is one big trick on the board which is
if the Rook takes the pawn
District yeah you are allowed to go Rook
takes night yeah Rook takes Knight would
utilize the fact that there's a pin on
the e-file for example after Pawn takes
we'll see a bunch of exchanges but at
the end probably white has a small
Advantage because the bishop will be
superior to the knights with horns on
both sides of the board this one is
getting very complicated now maybe we'll
see a retreat from Prague this is fine
but uh Gary will regain the pawn
we're expecting something just because
we know Prague so well we're expecting
something a bit more flashy yeah so this
is why I was thinking the Knight can
jump forward okay wow into yeah into No
Man's Land I know and it's just based on
one Chipotle which is the route comes to
the take the pool now you can take the
Knight now you would win a piece yeah
because at the end undefended but uh I I
might have uh sacrificed my kingdom for
a horse
because of course you know he's not
obliged to capture the porn yeah but how
does he save his Rook because he has to
stay defending its fellow here but now
suddenly I mean there's a lot of
tempting moves but for example you could
push forward in the middle of the board
um I was going to say maybe you could
push this Pawn forward as well but then
now this is the downside like get your
knight trapped there's no way back
and uh no way to escape for this night
at all actually and but he plays it he's
really taking his life into his own
hands here pregnant and he's gone in
he's a pawn up he's setting traps for
the opponent he's hitting this Rook
and Anish giri he has to be very
accurate here otherwise white is just
gonna emerge with a winning advantage
you've given up a pawn as an ishqiri not
for the first time in this match today
and uh you need to justify it
wow I mean I admire Prague as well if
I'm a point ahead in a match I just want
to play it safe but he's not
I mean he's showing zero fear he's just
not afraid of uh going all out even at
the cost of potentially trapping his own
Knight
what a game and uh okay Gary does indeed
shift his Rook across he needed to keep
the Rooks intact with each other and yes
he does push this Pawn forward so he's
trying to break his Knight out of jail
by getting rid of this Pawn maybe
creating an Escape Route there but also
undermining the defender of this Black
Knight
great move by Prague I mean the knights
sitting there on F7 it's going to get
out you think it's one it's gonna Escape
yeah yeah I'm inclined to agree the
evaluation part still says roughly level
but this is anything but drawish this is
anything but but boring this is uh maybe
one of the most complicated end games
you'll see in a while wow this is the
kind of position where Prague will be
thinking yeah I have the upper hand I'm
gonna win and uh Anisha is probably
thinking hey I'm in big trouble and uh
when you finish the game you put it on
the computer the computer case
slight Advantage exactly
you might have think he played the
perfect game you know prags he might
come out he might say oh I played a
masterpiece and then oh yeah it was a
couple of small mistakes here yeah
bigger mistake here that's always the
way the computer computer works but uh
we just have to calculate as humanly as
we can and accurately as we can and here
two minutes against two minutes the one
thing I will say about the clock is
under time pressure Prague is very calm
very composed Gary he did well in the
blitz tie break yesterday he beat Liam
there but he has panicked throughout the
season on the tour
pressure so
okay will history repeat itself there
is something with that the Indian kids
are fantastic out there they're
fantastic we're playing with no time on
the clock I mean they they play bullet
and like something called hyper bullet
with you know where they're playing with
30 seconds and they're playing great
games as well and they do this on a very
regular basis wow but uh it's not great
for your chest I have to say but uh
these guys are just fantastic they
calculate also so quickly they've been
training on calculation and seeing all
over just improving all over the board
Vision since they were tiny wow
yeah and uh Gary needs to use his full
board Vision here just to whip up some
counter play I'm struggling to see what
he can try I mean the first move that
came to my mind was using the Black
Knight on C6 and going to try going to
the edge of the board to try and attack
White's light Square Bishop white Bishop
holds the whole position together
White's Bishop defends his Knight if the
white Bishop Falls
White's position is done it just uh it's
like dominoes it will just collapse
but white Bishop can kind of hide and
Tuck itself away anytime it's attacked
and I don't really see a follow-up it's
getting very sharp and Gary's under one
minute
I think this might be the critical
moment of the whole game if giri doesn't
find a really clever plan now which I'm
struggling to see then he's just
Toasties are Pawn down with a bad
position okay David
I cheated only one move according to my
computer that says uh that maintains the
balance and that is the night sitting on
C6 has to attack the bishop and then
only after that attack can he trade
Pawns in the center wow and that would
come with a peace sacrifice okay let's
wait let's see what Gary does 10 seconds
10 seconds he has to move his Knight to
the edge of the board so the Black
Knight has to go to the A5 Square
anything else
he had three seconds when he played this
one but it's not just this move okay the
evaluation bar will recorrect itself we
think but it's not just this move the
next one is maybe even harder I feel you
mentioned the white Bishop is just going
to move it's going to retreat keep
itself safe Prague should play that
instantly because he doesn't really have
too many other options and uh after that
we will see the true testificarious
character of his nerves okay the bishop
does step back and he plays the best
move instantly Anish giri he was
calculating deeply the reason this is so
hard to work out is just because Black's
night now uh the Knight on f4 on the
right half of the board is undefended so
we're expecting a trade of Rooks in the
center on the e-file that tension is
unbearable you have to trade off a set
of Rooks and uh suddenly Black's Knight
will fall but
okay we see this variation happen
instantly the Brooks have disappeared
black snide did disappear as well and
after Pawn takes Pawn the whole point of
the variation will become clear if this
black pawn which is threatening to
promote actually in a couple of moves if
it is captured and I think we'll see
this on the board maybe we should show
it as well because black has given up a
whole piece on Instagram this is a
better piece sacrifice than the last
game at least but uh right now we need
to show why he has done this and that is
because after portex born you can't let
this Pawn live suddenly Rook down to the
second Rank and look at this bishop how
does it keep itself safe while
continuing to protect its Knight it
doesn't have too many squares if it
Retreats for example the night drops and
Gary is safe if it moves forward the
only safe Square on the diagonal is this
one it gets hit and uh we do see this
position on the board suddenly the
bishop is attacked and uh one of these
two pieces is about to fall
but it goes on actually it gets
complicated the bishop can Retreat
attacking The Rook
I think this is what Gary had spotted
maybe The Rook just moves and the Knight
is trapped the Knight is trapped but
still wow it kind of continues I mean
this this line is just so complicated
this is extremely complicated so Anish
giri he went down to three seconds but I
think he'd seen six or seven moves in
advance for both sides so extremely
impressive calculation to see all that
time ago that this Knight is trapped no
way to defend it no way home and uh yeah
I think we might see giri save himself
or at least get to an end game that
might be holdable
if you didn't find this variation he
could have just resigned essentially in
ishigiri so he's found the best bet even
if the computer thinks white still has a
small chance and okay prag didn't go for
this because the Knight would have been
trapped instead he knew one of these two
pieces is dropping so he gives up his
Bishop now if the bishop is captured the
White Knight Will Retreat and white has
won a pawn in the process this does
happen on the board the problem for
white is these two pawns aren't of great
quality they're isolated very weak easy
to attack for the black Rook yeah I
actually feel that black has very good
compensation just on account of those
two weak pawns and there we see Anish
just uh give an opening to his King yeah
if the king gets into the center of the
board it would actually double attack
against the rook and Knight together and
it would win a piece so yeah if anything
I I think I might even take black I
would take black as well I mean it's the
just an easy plan attack the pawns on
the left yeah nothing more sophisticated
than that meanwhile take a look at
White's pawns there on the right and
they're going to take a while to get
mobilized so I think this is great stuff
from pragananda he's trying to eliminate
his weaknesses and uh his Rook perfectly
safe you always have to worry a little
bit when The Rook is offside yep and
after this exchange the one thing that
Prague has to be careful of now is
Knights are notoriously bad at stopping
rook's pawns stopping A and H pawns so
this one will start running at some
point and White's Knight will not be
doing a great job even if Rooks come off
the board of stopping this Pawn so Gary
still has some small chances of not only
holding this game but trying to win it
as well 30 seconds against one minute
Prague here I think he would take the
draw at this point I think white just
needs to be a bit careful he pushes
forward he is attacking this Black
Knight but uh Guru says no I'm
retreating Knights are great blockadas
and uh White's Pawn is well guarded yeah
tense end game but things are
disappearing pieces are getting traded
off
most likely result your anchor I agree
and uh that would suit Prague but it's
been a it's been a roller coaster game
did put Gary Under Pressure
significantly he did uh Anish really had
to play very well find some resourceful
moves with seconds left on the clock and
there we see a trade of Pawns
the more the more trades that we see the
more the well that's the closer and he
gets to getting that draw yeah
I said when maybe we would choose black
but at this point
both sides have reason to be content and
yeah both sides are around 40 seconds
that should be enough there shouldn't be
too many complicated tactics yet uh in
the foreseeable future
so um yeah this one should fizzle out
now
okay Flex night
in the center looks well placed but a
bit loose I'm expecting at some point
pry to bring the white king closer to
the middle of the board
White's King does look a bit vulnerable
to some tracks on the second rank it
doesn't look it doesn't feel happy at
all and um yeah uh I agree uh just uh
step the king forward protect its pawns
and then this allows The Rook to now
swing over to the left side and start
attacking some pawns yeah white truck's
a bit tied down yeah free and up exactly
and uh also bear in mind that the black
king is still a little bit shaky and
prag down to seconds left on the clock
and there he go he moves his King
forward yeah good end game strategy when
in doubt if you don't know how to
improve your pieces centralize the king
and uh White's King does a great job of
supporting its pawns and this Pawn
however the white Seaport is attacked
Now by black and okay a check from
pregnant Yeah you mentioned the black
king it's kind of stuck on the edge
there uh it's not quite in a meeting net
but it's not too many safe squares to
run to Max King white gives a couple of
checks he's going to centralize his
Knight eventually I feel
there we go gaining time Craig can
repeat the position now if he's nervous
under 20 seconds he can repeat bail out
with the draw might bring his Knight
back to the top of the board that's the
second time we want to see in that
position and Gary uh would be
too reluctant to agree to that draw now
will we see this from Prague do you
think he's gonna keep going yeah of
course he's going to keep going it's
prag
he's calm under pressure and there you
see there is the Switchback I mean he's
gone to attack the a pawn so we're just
gonna see a trade of Pawns in effect yep
again disappearing pawns means that the
game is headed towards that dreaded draw
but at this point that would be a
logical result
I think Anish Gary will eliminate the
white C Pawn it's too dangerous you can
give a check with the black Rook on the
third rank first or you could go and
take that pawn and then give a check
maybe next move why tonight still needs
a while to get back into the center so I
don't think there's time for white to
profit from the two versus one Pawn
advantage on the right half of the bud
Yep this one is destined to be a draw
barring anything really shocking at this
point he gives a check first
asking a question of the white king we
did see a few minutes ago Wesley so
walked past and took a look at this game
he has finished game two and it's a bad
result for Wesley so he lost game two
against Liam Lee a first game was a draw
so he is now down in that match Wesley
so playing from San Francisco Arena it's
looking great for young Christoph Duda
in game two against momdarov and for
Magnus Carlsen he could go up by two
points against Sergeant Eric here in
game two this one
looks like Adriel then yep
against two pawns but I have to say I
would feel nervous with the white king
being so close to the black king nervous
for who is the white king gonna do the
check meeting or is it gonna get
checkmated that white king feels like a
hunter to me
and uh well and he's playing very
accurately mobilizing his King and uh he
should be out of danger although I say
this but I'm still very nervous yeah
I think you're right your bank actually
black has to be slightly careful I mean
now expecting White's Rook maybe even to
go to the sixth rank
um we don't see that he offers a trade
of knights first of all if the knights
disappear now then the white king is
perfectly placed actually yeah Black's
remaining Pawn that G6 porn incredibly
weaken in a rook end game alone suddenly
Black's apron not a factor those Rook
spawns A and H pawns are terrible in
Brooklyn games
wow yeah Prague putting Gary under some
pressure still
so cool he's just so good at 17 years
old pregnant and I mean I would have
bailed out with a draw I would have said
okay it was enough excitement for today
but uh no he keeps looking for chances
and he's so often rewarded yeah okay
Black's night not going for that
exchange I think that's a wise decision
from Gary A Night Exchange and White's
King and Rook would have been more
active than their counterparts but now a
check
is waiting time to pick off the black
pawns before white pawns for blacks
Knight is attacking as well
in the center vulnerable this black king
it is definitely vulnerable and uh there
we see the Rook swung across you know
white is getting ready to play F4 check
and this is getting very very dangerous
now for a niche yeah and uh Anish
holding things together he moves his
Rook back he is threatening now for the
black Rook to come and take the pawn
behind the white king distracting the
white king away from the defense of the
white Rook so uh Gary setting traps just
like he did a bit earlier in the game
both sides have reason to be optimistic
seconds yeah it's Prague low on the
clock though you went down to five
seconds there keeping his Rook on a safe
Square
Black's night retreating
finally it does feel like Gary's got
nice uh kind of coordination with his
pieces
but hang on a second this move perhaps
wasn't the most accurate I mean is there
any night checks yeah black snipe can go
to the H3 Square drop behind as it has
just done hitting the white king if the
white king had stepped forward and taken
the black pawn Black's Rook would have
swung across and taken a pawn to last
night has to retreat otherwise it was
trapped
I'm surprised we're still commentating
on this game to be honest because I
thought it would fizzle out to a draw
but both players are actually testing
each other this is really impressive end
game play the the balance hasn't been
Disturbed the status quo has never
really shifted either way but it's just
high quality Jess from both of them both
of them really want to win this one and
uh Prague is still trying his best
defending his pawns now
20 seconds against 30 seconds both sides
kind of gambling I think because uh
Prague has kind of put his King in a
very awkward position and it feels like
it could almost be checkmated at the
right time and uh here comes the a pawn
ah don't forget about Alice she is
running down the board
but first of all I'm expecting the black
pieces to do a bit of a shuffle okay no
he doesn't move his pieces Black's
formation can it be undermined can
White's Knight give a check to the black
king now can whites Rook check the black
king away
that black porn is actually scary it's
only three moves away no Defenders
around it this is a track Black's King
has a choice of two safe squares
takes a step back this is a smart move
and then it goes to the edge of the
board in order to threaten the pawn on
G6
it's it's Brave it's gutsy
and I think it works yeah it doesn't
work to win the game I think it works to
maintain the balance actually because
the position was sharpening up so much
yeah but this is suddenly far from a
draw because suddenly I thought Black's
Pawn on the a file is going to run
through and win the game or white knight
in the corner which looks weirdly placed
is going to come back and take take
Black's g-pawn and white will have two
running passports on the other flank
suddenly a draw is maybe not the most
likely result
Pawn has pushed this is stopped
prevented from advancing by white truck
I mean it's anyone's game now white king
could get greedy step up the board and
take a pawn
the white king could also step back and
attack this Black Knight gotta do that
take the pawn first of all repeat the
position this is always a good good
technique 10 seconds exactly and now put
the king back to where it came from and
then grab the pawn yeah but uh there's
also an argument to be made for grabbing
the other Pawn white throat can come and
take the black a pawn the problem is
white tonight in the corner is trapped
so you have to calculate that one quite
carefully
I think you can get away with it I just
want to eliminate that uh that scary
black porn on A3
okay first prank gives a check
does this help
and clear that King is kicked backwards
and now the king comes forward this is
the definition of teamwork and a big
threat on the board of Knight takes porn
meanwhile The Rook is guarding dangerous
a pawn
yeah it's it just feels like Prague is
the one putting the pressure on at any
moment but I can bail out even at the
cost of White's night as long as he gets
rid of two black pawns it's gonna be a
draw
um a Rooker Knight alone cannot beat a
rook so if one of the two sides gives up
their Knight for the opposition two
pawns it's gonna be a draw but uh it's
easier for Prague to do that than for a
nation look at this whoa this is what I
was talking about Prague is the one
putting the pressure on and Anish is
cracking suddenly the Black Knight is
offside
and blacks pawns both of them are
dropping White's night now swoops back
it takes him with a check and now the
pawns can uh just Advance push the F
Pawn and now Anish losing what a
turnaround he's definitely losing this
game all Prague needs to do is push his
two pawns White's Rook does a fantastic
job of stopping Black spawn it's game
over Black's night is just so bad push
your pawns that's all you need to do and
you can even just jump back into the
center with the white knight if you
really want to centralize but you to
push either of the two like points right
now to be honest both of them work black
is not there we go black is not
threatening to take this F3 Pawn with
the black Rook because white tonight
would jump back with a nasty Fork
all sorts of forks in the air with these
Knights now especially Black's King is
vulnerable
yeah Prague what a player he's gonna go
to a two nil Advantage here and that's
because he refused to accept a draw even
in a dead drawn position grinding it out
pressing and even the tiniest Advantage
I just love the way he kept posing
problems to Anish he never made life
simple and uh the king moves but now I'm
expecting the pawn just simply to step
forward yeah white F1 is now threatened
so why not Snap It Forward white tonight
could also re-centralize itself but this
is simpler teamwork again with the pawns
this time protecting each other and of
course the computer says no and whoa
Anish giri he found a really sneaky way
to pin the White Knight and uh there was
a threat there of black snake jumping
back and taking a pawn due to this pin
on the sixth rank but hang on a second
the acorn Canal March forward it's kind
of scary maybe has Prague let it slip he
has let it slip the most natural move I
don't know if he has because white
spawns are stepping as well
okay okay Anything could happen here
white spawns are very scary only three
steps away Black's Pawn is still under
lock and key still okay now Prague has
defended everything those two knights
are yeah not well placed at all but
they're doing a job and white tonight
especially is holding everything
together
last night can't get back in the game
there's a threat whites Rook wants to
take that black a pawn I think he's
still got it Prague but maybe Gary had a
small opportunity there I'm wondering
what it was but uh it really looks
devastated he does not look like he
believes in holding this one anymore
step forward two squares away this Jeep
one Gary the G Pawn is going to promote
Black's night too far away to stop it
yeah game over
it's uh no way to defend now no
absolutely
and okay he tries to get his note back
in the game but all you need to do now
as as brag is to step forward one last
time
check but uh I mean you could even maybe
capture that Knight with a rook but no
simpler to move the king
a new Queen is about to appear nothing
to be done Gary exhales
and he presses that resign button
pragnananda or he's about to at least
pregnant is going to take the win
second win of the day wow heartbreak for
Anish giri losing two games in a row
puts him in a must win City